in the song Anthony seems to grieve the
separation that has come between the
average person and the these rich
political Elites taxes the state of
wealth the welfare state the death of
young men in the country are all topics
the song touches on
here's what I love about this
the song has a message
it is a positive message we like
through his talent
and his Merit it has been discovered and
gone viral online creating a real
opportunity John Rich legendary country
star is now stepping in so we've got
here a couple things one I want to
outright just say you get woke you go
broke Bud Light loses 400 million
dollars they're selling off their craft
Brands Disney loses 900 million dollars
and then factory worker guy out in the
boonies in Virginia puts together a song
and boom Superstar